[Music]
hey youtubers is Charlie if you guys
didn't see it dave chappelle just
completely slaughtered his cold open on
Saturday Night Live he did this negan
skit basically a parody of negan's kill
in episode 1 so I'll just I'll play a
little bit here and then explain who
these characters are these are basically
like a greatest hits from his Chappelle
show from a long time ago
I just cannot decide which one of you is
gonna dance with death tonight wait I
got 19 bubble gum bubble gum in a dish
how many pieces do ya
how feels drunk Oh feisty would like
this well with all due respect mr.
Needham um and my line of work when
you're on your knees
don't give me bubblegum so you know the
bubblegum bubblegum is just a parody of
negan's eenie meenie miney mo as he was
trying to pick who he was gonna kill
this person here is Tyrone Biggums
everybody probably knows who he is even
if you don't remember Chappelle's Show
he loves doing crack probably one of the
most NSFW characters that he ever did
this person here is Andy silky Johnson
who was part of this player haters ball
sketch he was voted player hater of the
year he basically just hates on
everybody but the guy next to him who
keeps spritzing his jheri curl is
Donnell Rollins playing a character
named beautiful who in that same sketch
was hating on Charlie Murphy whose name
was buck nasty so it was basically just
like a bunch of pimps hating on each
other this pasty bastard oh god no
have some goddamn respect for yourself
man Oh what do you want money
sex sex isn't a chance of sex
otherwise this person is Chuck Taylor he
was basically like a news anchor meant
to be the whitest person you could
possibly imagine
so everybody knows little John he's
probably like the easiest character that
Chapelle ever did to identify know that
smell anyway frustration couple butter
looks like we got us Metro MUX
mug don't you realize your black hat
from what I hear this hat would say
otherwise
Trump's American man-boy well I stand
corrected and then this character here
if you don't remember him
his name was Clayton Bigsby he was a
member of the KKK but the joke was is
that he had been blind his whole life so
he was a member of the KKK but didn't
realize that he was black that's why
Chappelle as negan was like you know you
realize you're black then he puts the
maggot hat on really like the whole
point of the sketch like he had that
message at the end where he was like all
right you know let's all just chill out
a little bit so it was meant to be this
funny walking dead riff it was a total
home run but he was also kind of telling
America in general just to chill out
just because everybody's so crazy about
the election but for those of you that
are wondering what's going on with Dave
Chappelle like cuz he's so awesome like
he's still so funny he does a lot of
stand-up tours but he hasn't done a show
in a long time and if you never did
watch his show it was called Chappelle's
Show it only ran for a couple seasons
then it blew up he disappeared there was
this big drama that went on but he
basically walked away from the show from
a bunch of money just because things got
too crazy for him but he'll probably do
another show eventually so you can still
go see him on tour he's amazing it's
just that he doesn't do a lot of TV
stuff now that's why you don't hear
about him as much so get a new Walking
Dead posting tonight episode four be
sure to subscribe to get that I'll be
doing a walking dead giveaway and let me
know if you want me to do more funny
compilation videos they're a little
harder to do
on YouTube just because of the way
YouTube treats movie and TV content but
I might be able to do like funny
subtitles or something like that there's
probably something I can do I'll figure
it out eventually I'm always looking for
a new type of video to do but it just
depends on what you guys like so I might
try something like that next week well
you guys wait for that to post you can
click here for the trailer for the next
episode and you can click here for my
episode 3 Easter egg video thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight